What about turning the Republican party more Libertarian?
and you know this is something that my colleague Matt Welch
and my colleague Katherine Mangu-Ward,
people at Reason have, we've written a lot about it
and it seemed even a few years ago on the tea party wave and whatnot,
the people who were coming into the Republican party
were about limiting spending, balancing the budget,
getting out of a lot of social issues as a focus of national government.
Can anything be done to make the Republican party more Libertarian?
Yeah again I think so, but-
You can imagine-
I can imagine such a situation-
Now we're deep into like a Rick and Morty multiverse.
Right, so like-
In an alternative universe,
I can imagine such a situation
but it's hard to sort of perceive,
like just like it was hard to perceive the whole Trump thing
like that it was going to change the way the Republican party views itself
and change a lot of, a lot of people's positions.
I don't know, I think it's possible but again
if you could change the Speaker of the House
and have a Libertarian Speaker of the House
an independent minded Speaker of the House
you'd have a bigger chance of shifting the party.